il ya une vingtaine d'années j'ai
travaillé sur les dessins d'enfants et
ce qui m'a frappé à l'époque c'est que
jusqu'à la maternelle ils sont
extrêmement créatif volcaniques
et puis quand il arrive dans le collège
leur créativité diminue fortement
or aujourd'hui je pense que la
créativité
c'est ce qui peut nous aider dans le
monde incertain est de plus en plus
complexes que nous traversons alors
quand je me suis intéressée à tous
qu'ils étaient des personnes surdoué et
créative
je les ai appelés les multis potentiel
atypique
pourquoi multi potentiel atypique un an
un peu compliqué multi potentiel parce
que ce sont des gens qui ont des talents
multiples et atypique parce que ce sont
des gens qui pensent autrement
alors je vais vous faire un petit détour
enfin deux petits détours en réalité le
premier détour c'est élargissons notre
vision de la de l'intelligence
l'intelligent souvent nous avons une
vision de l'intelligence comme une
logique aux mathématiques verbal l'est
avec un esprit cartésien
or les intelligences multiples de la
théorie des intelligences multiples
développé par hohwarth garner un
psychologue américain en 1984 nous
montre que l'intelligence est beaucoup
plus est une notion beaucoup plus vaste
il a parlé d' intelligence émotionnelle
à l'intelligence intra et extra
personnel mais il a aussi parlé d'
intelligence comme l'intelligence
spatiale de frank ghery de l'architecte
ou l'intelligence qui n'existait
inès pesic de federer le champion de
tennis où l'intelligence musicale de
mozart
ensuite pourquoi c'est personnes je les
appelle les multis potentiel atypique
ils sont atypiques parce qu'ils pensent
autrement ils pensent différemment alors
là je vais faire un deuxième petit
détour en vous parlant d'une
neuropsychologue américains rogers
sperry qui en 81 a été prix nobel pour
avoir montré la symétrie cérébrale comme
disait louis à gauche c'est les cerveaux
gauches et l'irrationnel
à droite c'est lé cerveau droit les
créatifs
depuis les majri médical a fait beaucoup
de progrès et à montrer la complexité du
cerveau donc d'ailleurs qui n'a pas qui
ne nous a pas encore dévoilé tous ses
mystères mais pour les multis potentiel
atypique ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils ont
une pensée en arborescence ils ont une
pensée en arborescence qui est en
arborescence parce que elle et ils ont
une intuition extrêmement forte
ils ont une pensée disruptive pourquoi
une pensée descriptive
c'est une pensée qui fait beaucoup
d'associations qui fait beaucoup
d'analogies qui fait beaucoup de
connexions
je vais vous donner un exemple la grande
designer françoise perriand la française
veut peut-être peu connu mais qui a
travaillé avec le corbusier avait comme
mission de faire de créer un refuge en
montagne elle ne savait pas comment le
faire et elle s'est dit un jour elle
était en voyage en croatie et l aperçoit
un manège à vous me direz la connexion
entre manèges d'enfants et refuges de
montagne
en réalité elle est là un certainement
compris que à manège est un refuge de
montagne avait les mêmes contraintes
techniques
voilà la pensée en analogique que
peuvent avoir
un multi potentiel atypique un multi
potentiel atypique c'est aussi quelqu'un
de très rapide grâce à cette à son
intuition un multi potentiel atypique
c'est aussi un personnage visionnaire
visionnaire selon ses talents il a une
vision globale et là une vision à long
terme et là une vision stratégique et là
aussi une caractéristique très marqué un
multi potentiel atypique il est pétri
d'émotion il est né ponge à émotions
alors récemment j'ai une cliente qui me
disais oh yeah myriam moi je ne prends
pas le métro parce que toutes ces ondes
tous ces vibrations de gens qui vont pas
bien
je ne supporte pas d'autres personnes je
travaille beaucoup avec des grandes
entreprises et donc qui travaillent dans
les tours à la défense et dans ses tours
à la défense
il ya des open space et les open space
pour les multis potentiel atypique c'est
terrible parce que déjà qu'ils ont du
mal à se concentrer
si en plus il ya du mouvement et des
bruits autour d'eux c'est catastrophique
alors les multis potentiel ils ont aussi
une un rapport à eux mêmes très
particulier ils ont un rapport a même
qui quand ils ont vécu très bien à
l'école quand ça s'est bien passé
ils ont et quand ça s'est bien passé en
famille quand ils ont été reconnus aucun
problème
ça donne des bill gates s'adonne lester
job ça donne des richard branson des
dyson toutes ces personnes qui
réussissent magnifiquement par contre je
pense qu'il y en a une majorité qui sont
pas reconnus parce que ça peut être des
contrats l'école parce qu'ils s'ennuient
en fait ils s'ennuient et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de tous ces gens très
intelligents ne finisse pas forcément
leurs études
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben ils
vivent vous connaissez tous la fable du
vilain petit canard
vous savez que le vilain petit canard il
n'est au milieu ses frères et soeurs il
est rejeté et pourquoi elle est rejetée
il est différent on n'aime pas on ne
comprend pas jusqu'au jour où le vilain
petit canard tout
tous malheureux va circulent et découvre
des signes il rencontre un jour des
signes et là c'est le bonheur il
comprend il est reconnu et tout va bien
pour lui
alors c'est multi potentiel atypique
pourquoi quel qui ils ont en face d'eux
qu'ils sont les canards les canneurs en
fait ce sont des personnes qui sont
pétris de l'esprit cartésien qui sont
qui ont une pensée séquentiel une pensée
linéaire une pensée logique analytique
bref ils sont comme des cartons prouve
on raisonne mais par contre à ce que
leur reproche les multis potentiel
atypique c'est qu'ils ne sortent pas du
moule
il y pense on fait comme on a toujours
fait parce que pourquoi changer quelque
chose qu'on a toujours fait puisque ça
marchait jusque là alors cela je les
appelle les rationnels neurotypiques ou
d'un rationnelle ça sera plus simple
lors les rationnels qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent des multi potentiel ils se
disent comme disait louis tout à l'heure
ils sont ingérables
ils sont trop ils sont trop dispersés
sont trop brouillons
on les comprend pas alors moi
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a besoin de
toutes les intelligences
on a besoin de toutes les intelligences
mais si vous en êtes pas convié
si vous êtes un rationnel et que vous
dites non c'est pas possible c'est gens
là sont insupportables je vous propose
une recette
elle est simple si vous voulez vous
débarrasser de tous ces gens un peu
originaux atypique et qui vous racontent
des tas de trucs que vous comprenez pas
vous leur donnez des tâches simples
routinière vous leur mettez morcelé pour
peu qu'ils y perdent leur sens
vous leur mettez une hiérarchie
incompétente
quand ils font un super job vous trouvez
le détail qui tue la virgule qui est pas
au bon endroit et après avec une recette
pareil
a priori vous en débarrasser plus ou
moins vite alors vous comprenez bien que
c'est pas du tout mais pas du tout ce
que je vous propose
je pense que les multi potentiel
atypique
on peut on en a besoin et donc comment
comment les accueillir
c'est des gens qui ont besoin de défis
c'est des gens qui ont besoin de
challenge
c'est des gens qui ont besoin de sens
c'est des gens qui ont le souci de
l'intérêt collectif et qui ont envie de
travailler en communauté
donc si vous voulez les faire travailler
ensemble
vous devez essayer de trous de leur
donner des idées des projets multiples
parce que plus ils en font mieux et
sport à condition évidemment pas les
épuiser
alors pour conclure je dirais les
compétences des multi potentiel
atypiques sont pour moi particulièrement
intéressant parce qu'elles sont
complémentaires de ce que peut nous
apporter l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle elle sait
reproduire ne s'est pas innover aussi
tout ce qui est leur capacité à penser
autrement la capacité à être créatifs
leur sens de collectifs leur vision de
l'avenir peut nous aider alors je pense
qu il faut les connaître pour les
reconnaître et pour les accueillir
pourquoi parce que en les accueillant on
aura on aura une vision du futur qu'on
pourra voir se dessiner sous nos yeux
avec sérénité et avec optimisme merci
[Applaudissements]